Tâm dự báo ký tượng thủy văn Quốc gia cho biết báo số 12 fang xe
sân đang dí chuyển vào biển đông và sẽ thấy mưa lớn kéo sài khoảng
sống ngày từ 2,5 đến 2 bẩy tháng mười khiến lũ trên các sông từ
khoảng trị đến khoảng 9, có khả năng vượt mức báo động ma,
Kemp Waker Rú Quép, sạp lợn đất.
Dự báo sáng 2 một tháng mười báo còn kế khoảng 3,5% tả mười kì lâu mẹ,
mạnh lên cấp mười một, dật cấp mười ba sau đó đổi hướng
xuống tây Nam, sau tương tác không khi lại đến ngày 2,5 mười báo vặt động trên
phục biển tây báo khoảng xa với xức só cấp mười mề một,
dật cấp mười ba ngày 2,5 mười, anh hưởng chức tiếp phục biển từ vế đến khoảng 9,
bán chỉ đạo phòng thu dân sự quốc gia đã có công liện yêu cầu các địa
phương văn biển chủ đậu ứng phó, bảo đảng Anthuan Tau Thuyền và trên bị lực lượng
kéo hộ, gắt bộ, anh được sau nhận phủ, phối hợp chặt chẽ với địa phương chỉnh
kai phương An ứng phó báo.